Channing Tatum, what were you thinking?
This look says:
“I am the Douchiest elf in all of Middle
Earth!”
Wait I have more disses for Channing Tatum!
He looks like Link from Twilight Princess,
if he OD'd on HGH!
He looks like a level 63 Blood Elf
who moonlights at Chippendales!
He looks like Peter Pan
with several extra “Y” chromosomes!
He looks like a version of Spock
from a parallel universe
where everyone is FABULOUS!
He looks like a Yuuzhan Vong's
profile picture on GRINDR.
I assess the new movie Jupiter Ascending--
--on this week's episode of Angry Nerd!
First, your comments.
I asked you what you thought of
the Jupiter Ascending trailer.
The kindest comment
was that it looked like
a ripoff of the indie RPG
Stars Without Number.
Most comments just bagged on Tatum's ears,
and his apparent use of eyeliner.
Good call Buddy Smith,
he does look kinda like
Mugatu in Zoolander!
The Wachowski's new movie
is a target-rich environment.
For starters,
the protagonist is named Jupiter Jones.
What, is she
a distant cousin of Pluto Nash?
But what really broils my bantha
is that the movie is about
a janitor whose genetic signature
proves that she's a descendant
of galactic rulers.
I hate this strain of scifi stories
in which the characters are
fated to succeed.
Now, predestination isn't a new storytelling
crutch;
but it's lazy!
It's positively feudal!
It's UNAMERICAN!
Heroism is about smarts
and adaptability,
with maybe some bravery and self-sacrifice
thrown in there.
But fate or kismet?
No thank you.
This kind of thing reduces an epic saga
to a silly schoolboy's daydream
that he'd one day develop mutant powers,
and then he'd teach a lesson
to all of the bullies
who mocked his Jean-Luc Picard lunchbox,
and forced him to call home in tears and say,
“Mommy, I don't wanna go to college any
more!”.
--which happened to a friend of mine!
Lana and Andy Wachoswksi,
you don't return my text messages
,
but hear me out:
While you're working on
your upcoming Netflix show Sens8,
try to make sure the characters
aren't already a lock to save the world
in the pilot episode.
In fact, maybe do away with the characters
altogether
y’know, like you did
in Speed Racer.
Which movie hero do you think
had an unfair advantage over their foes?
Let me know in the comments,
and subscribe to the WIRED channel!
ALSO, you are predestined
to click on my other videos
that are over here to my left--
and your right!
Like them!
Add comments to each of them!
Do it!
Fulfill your galactic destiny!